but what's up guys is prestige here
alone you see my face and this is the
next episode I think 77 TSM depa sewed
in the minecraft herobrine series the
heroine experience i should say Jax I
should stop saying because the mod
stills not informed by 51 and I so I
haven't used them on a while but right
now I'm going in search of more trees
because I want different wood because I
don't want I don't want just Oakwood now
today we're also gonna be working oh
hello it's down here and nope today
we're also going to be working on the
house doing the buildings and past few
days up and doing a bunch of I was going
to ask you this was a ravine but it's
kind of like way too short oh I'll leave
you and past few days I've been doing
stuff like mining and stuff it's not
really pana and very building and that's
a big part of minecraft so we're going
to do that whew that's cool click there
are some caves in the mountain I want to
check that out we got burst so we're
also going to need to collect some SAP
in from these birch trees and I'm going
to need to go hit up the jungle
sometimes I'm going to want something
uncle would I don't shovel I have three
swords though oh that's great hola
sheepies
yeah this is what we come for so break a
few down then we'll go back and check to
see if any sevens of drops go dude and
you you guys have really been loving
this series like this it's worse for
than any series ever done it's getting
more support all dying it's coming night
and check the time before I left okay
let's see I'm going to have to not let
the leaves break on their own if I get
two saplings I'll be good okay you're
useless wall chap ends so you guys have
been love this so I will continue doing
it and lonely tears love it and even
though we haven't really seen hairpin
for a while ah because you guys seem to
like it I'm going to continue doing it
okay 33 is good I have to go home now ha
ha what looks like we're not going to
get a chance sticks with those caves
that's that looks like an awesome cave
just when I can like an alcove a cave
but cash or cash Abati's market details
also thinking I might cover the outside
my house oh aw crap crap ok we can I get
you crap crappity crap skype and make
that jump sprint yes this way whoo I
gotta make the house if I don't see any
creepers I'll be a-ok really all creamer
rice i say i was integrate for this you
think well at least I made that jump I
don't think that creeper notice me some
zombies up there Oh crates for you ok we
didn't have anybody else I can take him
don't blow up there we go click wit
Russian leaving doors wide open when I
go off into the night explore no I keep
that throw you in there like I was good
yeah screw 45 iron nice i'll deposit
most at most i said now i do want a
shovel so with the update we're able to
do a lot more stuff like you see that
clock redstone nice and dry vac some
shovel of sorts actually the swords i'm
going to do this haha asleep slip it all
slip at home
now to clear the premises of creepers or
zombies hide you know and creepers he
can resist to resist the attacking me
now turn out a little time oh oh crap
how you not dead the oven zombies aren't
fire they catch you on fire partly
update to our knowing but something ways
to deal with nonetheless don't think
we're gonna have enough there to patch
this up now don't need you so we to do
now I said I don't want to use y'all
stop a dart yeah I'm not gonna have
enough let's click some dirt from places
where it's not needed that be then haha
oh no what a perfect web-site at the
perfect all right now I should probably
finish this other building so let's
connect let's connect my house and I
like you're getting too wide okay so not
really sure what I want to do here
thinking maybe maybe make it a
cobblestone or stone brick why don't you
stone brick phone abuse on break we need
to cook up all my cobblestone right
yeah I do stone brick and the roof or
just do birchwood what to do what to do
anything only get sunburned case it
looks like idea just chop this town no
going away I can plant the saplings take
so we get more birch trees or creeper
weights gedeon see me ooh quick quick
creeper hi you did another one right
there and never won over there I want to
XP wonder can you make a squid farm
anything squid breed with I don't think
so I would that no but not sure do to do
you should make a dime pic of the times
i have that would be a good idea due to
22
okay we have 16 and it means we can make
with the heck fail sixteen stone bricks
now we're going to just get a look get a
feel for how it's going to look I think
I'm going to need all this number can
meet at this town I'm making to make
this it looks good where I think it
looks good you guys think it looks good
tell me think don't think it looks you
tell me see travel make my Road out of
gravel so I'm going to do that should
make the inside of here not cobblestone
we good idea then we'll make a road
going all the way down to the sea yeah
that's cool that's cool
so if I'm going to do that I don't think
we're going to have enough gravel I can
drop it right here
crap again right here let me get up I
want you here because no one's going to
put under the difference that are 20
even do to do to do all so close so
close man up yes is it good
yo man a path for it
so let me get some more gravel will
finish it and I'll push you back a bit
let's not do that it's a little bit
better now ye yes 30 awesome yeah
that'll be enough pick the other stuff
that dropped up once i'm done so yeah
yeah you can mix don't mix lab i don't
think i'm going to want to do that make
stone slabs let's happy good looking
so put you right there so the line is
like that I look good mmm there be kind
of opposing buildings but I think you
look cool pop Street some noms it's an
ami foods our to do what to do not the
birch trees have grown Ian's sadness I'm
going to do it and you you guys since
you guys tell me in the comments if you
think what I'm doing is smart or you
don't like it if you don't like Evan
tell me 18 that is not going to be
enough oh [ __ ] turn these back pain you
make a those all right well we need to
cook up a little bit more stone and
you'd probably gonna need more than that
but oh well Oh what now make this extend
all the way except not in the back so I
made in the pacu kind of boyish huh
actually I think you'll have enough yeah
had enough what you know
and they connect so it's kind of cool
all right i'll leave that cocoon and i
can break this piece now should i do the
awful place the stone i can run around
place it 20 file files to loosen see I
break it turns back in the cobblestone
so that I hover I'm so touch peak oh is
that good it looks good I got to kick up
some more this cowl let's like half of
this probably all of it and it's are you
in there let's organize my stuff a
little bit this is a book blocks are you
in there and oakwood where I get all the
Oakwood from I think I just the stuff
that I kept yeah probably you need to
organize organize a little bit like
these are the goods they've got the
books I've got some foods I did some
organization so it's cool ok 222 that is
too high that isn't like I should make
it lower resin it's two blocks i also
wanna make some Doris I'm going to make
I'm going to make the mine a lot better
I will definitely make this model better
but I want to put it on to put a doorway
here say I make two doors up to pum pum
pum pum
then make two more like that I'm going
to need to move my chest I have to
accommodate them like that I like fun
think it would hard I know how to make
it look good ye rain in this way ya
wanna know the status to have another
stack poop yeah buddy is gonna look
great yeah well I can get a pair for
this
so fair enough that end here also yeah
tell me if you guys like the peaceful
peaceful days like this where I just
build ensign do it but I'm really going
to keep going if you guys enjoy it the
gravel road should make I should make a
bridge on here like taking into that
line Gobert sugar you can't really see
that part that I added in from ground
level but i think it's going to look
better yeah definitely looks better we
got here so I'll make this a more secure
yeahh shall make your fences mmm the
offenses look freaking cool ground when
you find this I'm going to need more
sticks point you should be enough I'm
going to turn all defenses I'm not now I
want to take you out take you out take
you out take you up we have seven fences
will happy enough most likely not no it
will not be enough I'm going to connect
here here here here here here here
hahaha ya need two more i'm going to do
any more sticks for more should be
adequate oh my god fail there we go boom
right and for the above parts I'm going
to have to throw something some slabs
well I'm I'm just putting it there for
now so I can do this no don't want to do
that we don't want any spider jump in
and above well if we're going to do that
and let's at least make it look good
Hitler stencil open fine that's good it
would definitely go to change this is
probably going to make my move taller
all right now time to finish the roof
over here since we don't want unfinished
roof hanging about I think I will have
enough yeah well awesome dang if I ever
want to make this roof figure I'm going
to have to break all the Sun make much
new stone then yeah I left my doors wide
open again I mean all go we had a group
of creepers I happen to have to take
care of them because i do not want a
time coming to my house
one more here we go all me just wrecking
like a boss and let's plant all of you
guys yeah that's good all right cool I
can't place towards as a half-size I've
got actually I just didn't know that
that's a good lighting also light here
so it looks a little better it is much
better she's also i'm going to light
this stuff up on that too all right well
we created an addition to our house we
created a safe passage to her mind
awesome man let's see I think the video
is about when you're drawing yeah okay
sorry still a little sick what no oh
dang parent you guys all this stuff when
you shouldn't have alright guys I hope
you enjoyed this video my name is
prestige if you did enjoy it leave it a
like comment subscribe and if you're new
subscribe if you really love like love
this was like the best thing ever your
favorite it but yeah so I hope you don't
enjoy it um i'll be posting more the
stuff and until i see you next time
peace out wash ah